far across the sea
an island calls
nothing never stays nice
it always sounds bad
things aren't always nice you can change
them
no
the way we always do
we fight
how far will you go to save the ones you
love
a plague tale requiem picks up a few
months after the end of innocence
right around the first days of summer
amecia and hugo are headed south along
with their mother beatrice and the young
alchemist lucas reaching places still
spared by the devouring plague
the raging wars and the rabid rats that
are running rampant in the north
is that affair
beneath the warm sun of 14th century
provence
the darunes are almost able to enjoy a
normal life
[Music]
but for a recurrent dream that hugo has
been having of a mysterious island that
calls
it's a him island
how come nobody noticed that
disappearance maybe nobody cares
maybe
one day the immaculate illness that's
been dormant inside hugo awakens and the
dreaded living nightmare begins again
in the wake emacia finds herself with no
other choice but to trust her brother's
dreams and head further south towards
the elusive island
before he's consumed by the terrible
macular affliction the bite yes
they brought the arena down but let them
die here
all over again
her mind is made up
she will find a cure in what dreams and
prophecy may hold get used to it with
almost no one they can trust this is
your life now emicia and hugo must
traverse land and water as restless
forces stand against them
after the events of last winter
the mesia
and when backed against the wall can be
surprisingly resourceful
with several new tricks up her sleeve
she is now able to freely choose between
striking from the shadows
or unleashing hell with a variety of
equipment and tools
hugo wants more than ever to help his
big sister and not hinder their progress
within him is a double-edged sword that
has deepened his connection with the
rats perhaps
they can feel people's blood
now i can
this powerful ability can decimate
entire squads of soldiers
but takes a severe toll on hugo every
time he uses
thankfully their journey brings not only
hardship but also unexpected friends
these colorful characters help the
darunes carry their terrible burden it's
not my first time while offering unique
skills and resources to bring them
closer to their elusive goalie
[Music]
and hugo the road ahead will test the
limits of what they can endure on all
levels
and just how far they're willing to go
reaching the island is only the first
step to truly understanding the terrible
affliction that stricken their family
as the lines between reality
fantasy and fate dissolve
keeping it together and finding the cure
to save hugo
will be nothing short of a miracle
but emesia has hope
and hope is the last thing lost
others
if you kill be ready
a plaguetale requiem releases october
18th on xbox series
wow what a journey i don't know about
you but i've been eager to get back to
the rats infested france of the 14th
century which is a sentence i never
thought i'd say and it's in part thanks
to this guy over here kevin chateau game
director for a plague tell requiem
releasing this fall kevin thank you so
much for joining us today thanks for
having me i'm super happy to be here
it's such a good day so we're gonna dive
right into that trailer as it mentioned
this is the follow-up to the smash hit
innocence so i was wondering if you can
catch us up to where amusia and hugo are
up to now so um the game takes place in
the 4th 14th century south west france
they are
they came from the southwest but they
had to flee because of the event of the
first one
and so we joined them six months after
the event of the first one on the road
uh they are arriving in the province so
south east front and we are going to
explore this region
and also a bit of the mediterranean sea
lovely so for those who haven't or
people are waiting to jump right into
requiem i should say but maybe they've
not played innocence um would you say
it's recommended reading is it important
to go back i'm certain you'll say it is
but what do you think for new fans no of
course
yeah absolutely no no it's um
[Music]
we have a re
not rebooted but rethink everything in
the game so
it's a brand new game we have done
everything to
uh on board everyone joining uh a
collected universe so even if you
haven't played the first one you can
jump in it it would be good for you
absolutely so i was actually wondering
if you could talk a little bit about the
um the sort of accessibility and the
onboarding that you've done and what you
had in mind during development what some
of the key changes coming to requiem
especially for those who loved the
original as well
so then
there's a lot of new things of course
you've seen it in a trailer um in terms
of gameplay it's much more wider bigger
uh
much more open than the first one was
yeah i picked up on that actually yeah
yeah it was quite narrow the first one
so we were able to open it even further
and offer new tools to amicia like the
daily crossbow she has now or
the knife she can use quite the arsenal
she's got with her now yeah yeah and
then it's it's quite different for us
for her because now she's using war
weapon
it was not something she was doing in
the first one
so she she's ready to deal with death
much more than very ready deal with
death and deal out death by the looks of
the trailer so you mentioned the word
new a lot and i think it's important to
point out that this is the new console
generation that we're working with at
the moment so um what kind of shiny
current gen features can we expect to
see in requiem so there's many things
again um the first one that comes in my
into my mind is uh we have uh pushed the
fascial expression the demo cap even
further it was a brand new thing for us
we had no mock-up on the first one so we
build up our studio we've learned new uh
new ways to work so we've improved this
aspect of the game and visually it's
much more stunning than the first one
was
um we've um
we wanted a larger game as i was saying
but uh we needed then more light because
the light is a key element of our
gameplay i love the way every new thing
brings its own problems that you have to
overcome yeah so we have
a much more wide area so it means more
light lights is very uh expensive in
terms of performances for the game so it
was a big challenge but also of course
wider space we need
to fill it with something yeah
so we we jump up from 5 000 to 300 000
right on the screen that's a lot of rats
to begin with so sorry say that one more
time that's five thousand to three
hundred thousand yeah that's it
are you not okay that's a lot of rats to
put in the video game
well i was gonna say well thanks to all
of those rats it does mean that um when
we say that emission hugo have been
through quite a lot i think it's a
little bit of an understatement
especially now um and at the end of the
day they're actually still children if
there are anyone out there who didn't
know that much background from the story
so um how do you go about showing their
relationship in an authentic way after
everything that they've been through
together it's about to do that because
they've been through a lot they have
experience
they were almost
dead sometime and a lot of people around
them
died
so they have to grow up be much more
mature than
what they should be at their age
it's about to build up a
story and convey a
convincing dialogue
for children
fortunately the team is quite old now
and
age is part number
but um and we a lot of us have children
so we we can
be inspired by them and and try to feel
the best way to convey uh children
emotion to the players it must be a very
difficult one to do though i mean as a
parent myself like i can only reasonably
say that i hope i never see my children
go through what happens in that game so
what's that sort of like to go yeah
we're reflecting the childlike
experience in the game but also
committing terrors to them yeah
this is something we have no
no inspiration from to take from because
yeah again you don't want to be inspired
by that too
of course no
yeah well fair enough um we're going to
focus a little bit now specifically on
amisha uh as in innocence we saw her
wielding a crossbow
she's way more prepared she's way more
confident dangerous and all round i
think you'll agree a bigger all-round
hero to hugo so how do tactics change in
requiem and what does that mean for the
people playing as her so um yeah as the
prepared is the is the right word uh
she's
she's ready she don't want uh just only
to survive or to escape she's ready to
fight if she needs to absolutely but
she's not forced to
so the player can choose the way you
will approach this oh interesting okay
so you can go uh full stairs if you want
you can go full combat everything is
still there from the first one so but
right now you can choose to approach a
situation the way you want
so it's not that only the space that is
wider but also the way you will approach
things yeah and by full combat you me i
mean we saw some stuff from the trailer
like you all out combat right yeah yeah
you can burn people you can use the
crossbow to kill them instantaneously or
you can use the knife to silently kill
them it's all there it's absolutely all
there and i think that all comes
together and making the experience so
much more cinematic
which i want to talk about now because
the other thing that's so fantastic
about the title is the voice acting and
i think that becomes essential when you
want to convey emotion so i'd love for
you to share a little bit of insight
about the development process working
with the the voice actors and getting to
the voices of the emotion that we hear
in that trailer
so it's funny because it's something
that people don't really know but when
we are working on the game for several
years
we don't work with voice actor
instantaneously so for like two or three
years we work with a text-to-speech so
robot voices
and for an emotional game it's a bit
hard and it takes you out a little bit
yeah it's like when you use your
smartphone it's a flat voice
with no emotion no punctuation nothing
that makes really sense so it's really
hard to keep your focus on the story
some time to understand what is the
purpose of seconds
it's yeah after 16 hours of breakthrough
you're like
i think i don't get the story at all
sure interesting that it changes that
much i will say first of all i would
love to see that version one day it does
sound wonderful um so do you wanna what
was the process like working with the
voice actors so when the voice actor
arrived it changed everything uh because
we were uh able to work again with
charlotte mcberlin and
logan anand which were the actor for
amisha hugo from the first one
and
we were so in love with the acting it
was a game changer for us to have them
back in the game
um they
when they arrive their voices arrive in
the game uh the game change uh i was
going to say imagine it's a little bit
of a chicken and egg situation with
voice acting who informs the character
is it you guys designing the character
or does the voice actor come in and
actually completely change the scene
actually it's both yeah we prepared
everything and they react to what we've
wrote and they say no i think amsterdam
should say it like that a bit more like
that so we change that on on the fly
with them and adapt the game sometimes
to their their feedback to make it even
better and even more accurate they are
still children and we are not anymore so
i love that they have their own feedback
as well is their character right it's
it's their character that they're
conveying so big love for them to feed
him back as well right well lastly for
anyone who is watching this segment out
there who can't wait to play requiem in
october which by the way is day one on
xbox game pass and maybe you're not here
in gamescom as well i'd love to know
what you would like to tell the folks at
home about requiem so we're super glad
to have it day one on that on the day
on game pass because it means that a lot
of players will be able to try the game
and to give us feedback because i really
want to see their reaction you know i
can't wait to see that we've built up
the games in several years and we write
up this big story and i really want to
see people reaction to that and the
community have been really close since
the first title as well yeah yeah and
it's thanks to them that we were able to
do the sequels so uh um yeah we're super
loved letter to them yes by the courier
device of rats three hundred thousand of
them to be nice three hundred
thousand rats of love
[Laughter]
absolutely fantastic well thank you so
much for joining me i'm a massive fan of
series and i cannot wait to get my hands
on it thank you again yeah thanks so
much for joining us but when it comes to
self-care you